ce matin plusieurs explosions retenti au
dessus de la capitale
ukrainienne donc on a entendu le travail
de la défense antiérienne
ukrainienne apparemment il y aurait eu
au moins deux missiles Kinja lancé par
les forces russes contre la capitale
vous l'avez mentionné l'un de ces
messies et désintégrer au dessus d'un
hôpital pour enfants il y a eu des
dégâts matériels on n'a pas encore de
d'informations sur d'éventuelles
victimes sur d'éventuelles blessées donc
la capitale une nouvelle fois visée il y
a ce genre d'alerte aérienne qui
retentit quasiment quotidiennement ici à
Kiev mais c'est vrai que ça faisait un
moment que nous n'avions plus entendu
c'est explosions donc de nouvelles
attaques contre la capitale
ukrainienne qui ont retenti ce matin